that Jonathan high he did this really
interesting study the idea of echo
Chambers conservatives consistently are
better able to identify what the left
believes in vice versa right because
it's frankly a little bit hard to live
in an echo chamber if you are right wing
nowadays right your your government is
left-wing your media is left-wing Your
Entertainment is left-wing your
schooling is left wing so I mean
obviously especially if you're in social
media and your friend group that could
absolutely be just full of conservatives
right Wingers you don't have any
exposure to actual leftists but you're
not going to get the same amount of
ideological Purity that you can on the
left and I think that is why the left
more so than the right has been
radicalized and that we can see this
when we look at like the positioning of
the democratic party over the past few
decades that has shifted much further
left compared to any transformation
that's happened